Sad news from the boxing world tonight. The Associated Press is reporting,...
...that boxing legend Joe Frazier has died.
And Frazier is best known for his three battles with Muhammad Ali in the 1970s.
But since October, Frazier had battled liver cancer.
Jeremy Schaap with more on the life of Joe Frazier.
At the moment in his life when it mattered most,...
...with hundreds of millions of his fellow humans invested in the outcome,...
...it was Joe Frazier who emerged victorious.
Somehow, the fight lived up to its billing.
Frazier withstood Ali's early onslaught and slowly built momentum,...
...eventually grinding Ali down.
A third fight against Ali, which stunned Foreman the year before.
The epic "Thrilla in Manila" was gory and glorious.
The protagonists were both past their peaks,...
...but they put on a brilliant, devastating show.
After the 14th round, Frazier's trainer, Eddie Futch, refused to allow him to continue.
Frazier had lost. But in losing, he had honored himself.
When it was over, Ali said, "I'm just happy right now that there ain't no more Joe Fraziers to fight."
In retirement, Frazier remained a constant presence ringside in big fights,...
...in beer commercials, in interviews, where he alternately expressed anger and admiration for Ali,...
...his eternal opponent.
Overshadowed by the man he defeated in his most significant fight,...
...Frazier goes down as one of the great heavyweights.
If Ali was the hope, the face, the voice of a movement, Frazier was instead a fighter's fighter.
That was good enough for him.